just
very wise that we are going that way with Allen
but the scoop on top is the problem
also from the PvdA
because we have calculated so
what the green deal from Mr. Timmermans
has cost from Europe
that costs 26,000 euros per person in the Netherlands
that is the paid sum for the people
then we are talking about it
off the gas and it helps
the compulsion the heat pump that must be purchased
making houses hospitable
it is 1 operation of too much we think
too much on each other
with 1 minute result
but also too much in one go
as in the Netherlands
be 1 small country in big Europe
but even bigger the world where america
India you also know China for increasing CO2 emissions
put the 1 on the table after the other
plus new fashion neutral
do you think I have
where exactly is the Netherlands in this story
working effectively on our money
do you have billions
take useful spending